question is
what form factor of robots are you most
excited about for the future
bipeds quads arms humanoids
maybe something else more obscure
this is a really tough question because
i really like robots
i think that love is born in
software and uh the hardware stuff just
makes it a little more fun
so i think the things i'm really excited
about even in terms of form factors is
in the software
i think much of the exciting
developments in robotics is actually in
simulated worlds
currently and i think that will be true
for quite a while to come
and so i think in terms of human robot
interaction
the robots that will be really exciting
are the ones that live in virtual worlds
like
in virtual reality or even just on a
screen
so i think what we would see more and
more
is entities human-like entities
or entities that allow us to
anthropomorphize
a consciousness a spirit
onto them living in the digital world
i think that's what i'm really excited
about
and of course slowly those entities
taking a form in the physical space
in terms of i think probably the
humanoid form
unfortunately though very difficult to
engineer and
create a uh
realistic and natural fulfilling
experience with
i think it's still probably the most to
me exciting form
although i do really like boston
dynamics spot
the robot dog from
kind of having a pet perspective is a
really exciting form
again very difficult to do stuff in the
physical space
it's uh it's a huge engineering
challenge
that as far as i can tell is several
orders of magnitude
more difficult than the same challenge
in the digital space
so i just see the digital simulated
robotics advancing much quicker and
having a much
larger scale impact on the world
especially if we start seeing more and
more
virtual worlds being created and that
that doesn't necessarily mean virtual
reality or like augmented reality
it just means ability and mediums within
which you can interact with artificial
intelligence systems
in the digital space and i do see that
as a
form factor which is entities in digital
space
having a humanoid or a semi-humanoid
form
something that we can anthropomorphize
something we can connect with on a human
level
you